hoje eu vou contar pra vocês é o que eu
aprendi trabalhando com pessoas que
vivem em situação de rua e com isso eu
espero mostrar o quanto nós podemos
aprender e evoluir como ser humano
através do exercício da empatia mas
antes de começar é eu gostaria de
perguntar que quem sabe o que significa
simpatia simpatia seria o mesmo que
empatia não simpatia é um sentimento de
afinidade que atrai identifica as
pessoas uma pessoa simpática é uma
pessoa agradável delicada já empatia é a
habilidade de se colocar no lugar da
outra pessoa
compreendendo os seus sentimentos suas
necessidades ou desejos e ações
imaginando-se nas mesmas situações
daquelas pessoas e sim a empatia é um
sentimento que pode ser desenvolvido
exercitado não necessariamente não
necessariamente algo que na sua gente
podemos desenvolver lá e até mesmo se
tornar um hábito mas como que a empatia
entrou na minha vida eu sempre tive
vontade de fazer um trabalho voluntário
em alguma instituição
o meu desejo era trabalhar com um e
ajudar pessoas que tinham algum tipo de
vulnerabilidade social
o que eu queria mesmo é olhar o mundo
como essas pessoas olhavam mergulhar na
vida dessas pessoas sentiram que ela
sentiu e porque também não será ajudado
de alguma forma poder ajudar essas
pessoas entendê las e respeitá las mas
essa chama esse desejo de fazer trabalho
voluntário
ele ficou parado por muito tempo e
durante o doutorado em são paulo é eu
dei o pontapé inicial e minhas
atividades de voluntariado
quando eu vi uma matéria sobre um
projeto chamado entrega
por sp que atuava com pessoas em
situação de rua que a maioria chama
erradamente de moradores de rua e pior
nem digo aquela reportagem ela me chamou
a atenção pois ali estava algo que eu
sempre tive muita curiosidade em saber
eu sempre tive interesse desde pequeno
em conhecer um pouco mais sobre aquelas
pessoas
quem eram os seus nomes porque elas
estavam naquela situação
enfim saber a sua história
a partir dessa reportagem eu iniciei
minhas atividades como voluntário nesse
projeto em março de 2005 e iniciava
naquele momento um novo flávio a fase de
maior mudança e revisão de conceitos e
preconceitos que eu já vivi
existe um flávio antes e depois daquela
primeira ação que eu participei em uma
noite quente de verão paulistano isso um
paradoxo ao mesmo tempo que o calor
climático tomava conta
eu percebi o confraria invisível
solitária triste e difícil era a vida de
quem vivia nas ruas
já na primeira ação que eu participei eu
tive ensinamentos que me fizeram
refletir e evoluir como cidadão o
primeiro ensinamento veio completo
ele foi conceitual e de vida
eu conversava com o morador e eu
perguntei pra ele quanto tempo ele
morava na rua
ele prontamente e corrigiu meu camarada
não mora na rua eu morar na rua eu sou
atropelada e morreu
e prosseguiu e por mais ruim que a minha
vida seja eu quero viver eu moro nas
calçadas nas praças embaixo de marquises
pontes mas não na rua
já no começo da relação o primeiro tapa
na cara bem dado
diga se de passagem eu nunca tinha
parado para pensar nisso e faz todo o
sentido
eu tive um ensinamento conceitual que
ele não morava na rua e ensinamentos de
vida por mais um link na vida dele
estivesse ele queria viver viver a noite
prosseguiu e no último ponto daquela
ação separada daquela ação eu me deparei
com o senhor josé que na época tinha 72
anos
o senhor josé estava dormindo embaixo de
uma marquise de um papelão
nós nos aproximamos pedimos licença
afinal aquela lá era a casa dele
nós agimos como se fosse a nossa casa e
batemos um longo papo senhor josé e no
final da do nosso bate-papo um dos
voluntários foi até seu carro um
travesseiro e um pedaço de espuma o
tamanho de um colchão de de solteiro
entregou o senhor josé josé colocou
aquele pedaço de espuma no chão eo
travesseiro deitou e começou a chorar
desesperadamente ao mesmo tempo e
energia mão por céu e falava obrigado
meu deus aquela foi uma das cenas mais
marcantes que eu já vi na minha vida até
hoje um senhor de 72 anos em uma
situação de vulnerabilidade extrema
agradecendo o poder
naquela noite dormiu confortavelmente no
pedaço de espuma não deve senão
travesseiro no mesmo dia
embora a ação chegar em casa eu fui
tomar um banho e você imagina o choque
que foi
e começou a cair uma água quente nos
meus ombros
o shampoo sabonete um pedaço de esponja
puxa uma toalha chegar no meu quarto e
ter uma cama box ortopédica densidade 33
uma grande reflexão situações que eu
nunca tinha parado para pensar afinal
era algo tão normal pra mim bastou eu me
colocar no lugar de seu josé
para ver um mundo diferente dos olhos
eu só tenho a agradecer a deus pelo seu
josé ter entrado na minha vida
ali foi um divisor de águas a certeza de
que a população em situação de rua seria
a minha causa
eu participei um ano e meio o entrega à
psp e ao voltar para cuiabá e
desenvolver minhas atividades acadêmicas
no fmi deus o professor do curso de
medicina
[Música]
eu me senti na obrigação como cidadão de
trazer aí a idéia da entrega da nossa
cidade
afinal um projeto que mudou tanto a
minha vida tanto tanto vocês não
imaginam quanto também pode mudar a vida
de outra pessoa de outras pessoas
é um ciclo vicioso o segundo bem e assim
iniciou entrega para cuiabá
nesses quase dois anos de projeto
eu vivenciei as mais diversas situações
e histórias e chorei
aprendi muito e todo esse aprendizado é
construído através da empatia para com
os amigos em situação de rua e torna a
cada dia mais consciente do meu papel
como cidadão e da minha responsabilidade
como educador o exercício da empatia que
eu fábio
tenta exercer no mesmo dia a dia me toma
o torna mais humano
deem uma olhada na quantidade de
sentimentos
tu diz e percepções é que nós podemos
aprender com os amigos em situação de
rua amor e amizade
não há nada mais profundo que essa
imagem
ela diz muito sobre o amor ea amizade
que nós encontramos nas ruas os animais
de estimação especial os cachorros são
os verdadeiros amigos dessas pessoas e
na maioria das vezes são a sua família
com eles dividem a cama comida
a vida nunca me esqueço
uma de nossas ações nós levamos um kit
que tem itens de genji de necessidades
básicas de um lanche e eu entreguei um
antes e um amigo que tinha dois
cachorros
ele partiu o lanche ao meio de metade
para cada cachorro
esse gesto é muito forte
obviamente que nós temos um outro grande
prega o amor e amizade também visto nos
abraços calorosos abraços calorosos que
nós recebemos recebemos essas pessoas
nas palavras de carinho nos gestos de
gratidão
eles entendem que nós estamos lá a dar
visibilidade para eles eles são
invisíveis à sociedade essa é a
realidade
nós estamos lá para mostrar que eles são
importantes para a sociedade
tem uma frase do guarani é o que diz o
amor que a rua dá só quem vive arroz em
ti solidariedade
eles são muito solidários por conviverem
diariamente com a dificuldade
eles sabem dividir
nós aprendemos solidariedade com essas
pessoas diversas vezes nós tentamos
entregar 34 peças de ouro
eles falam uma só basta tem mais gente
precisando leva a outra pessoa
nesse dia este ano
ele só estava com uma calça e um
cobertor e não tinha nenhuma camiseta eu
levei várias camisetas para ele
modificar não uma só tem mais gente
precisando leva pra outra pessoa
nesses momentos eu e meu guarda roupa
cheia de roupas e calçados
cabe aqui uma reflexão a respeito
aprendemos muito essa virtude com as
pessoas em situação de rua
aprendemos a respeitar o momento a
individualidade o sono mais que
queiramos bater papo levar carinho e
atenção
eles também têm um momento de não querer
conversar e não serem incomodados e nós
não pomos o nosso desejo em detrimento
do deles
esse é o seu e aya o morador que vive na
região do porto
eu cheguei acordei ele pergunta se nós
poderemos conversar batan papa e hoje
não
embora hoje eu não quero conversar
chama atenção porque eu me agachei
esse é outro ponto do projeto nós somos
todos iguais
se ele está agachado deitado eu me
agacho dele olhando olho no seu superior
se ele tem pernas conversamos em
terceiro está sentado a gente conversa
sentado respeito também
entre os voluntários que participam do
projeto
nossas ações não importa a crença
religiosa filosofia política e ideologia
política
a etnia o gênero e jimmy torce e essa
foto essa imagem
representa muito dessa diversidade estão
todos ali ó juntos unidos em prol do
mesmo objetivo que é levar amor ao
próximo
o exercício do respeito
ele acontece do início ao fim a entrega
por cuiabá
aprendemos a escutar através da empatia
e da doação dos nossos ouvidos nós
escutamos maior desejo da população de
hoje de nossa cidade que era a
possibilidade de tomar um banho
isso mesmo você já se imaginaram ficar
15 dias sem tomar banho
é isso que acontece com essas pessoas
eles não tenham de tomar banho
por isso nós unimos esforços
fizemos um financiamento coletivo na
internet e com a ajuda de 148 pessoas
nós realizamos o maior sonho de entrega
por cuiabá até o momento que foi a
construção do banho solidário que é um
reboque adaptado que possui um banheiro
masculino e um banheiro feminino em que
esse amigo pode tomar um banho quentinho
porque ele dispõe de um aquecedor na
parte traseira do reboque
nós temos um espelho torneira em uma pia
para que ele possa se ver o seu cabelo e
fazer a barba
escovar os dentes então esse amigo chega
sujo com roupa suja nós entregamos uma
roupa limpa ele toma banho faz a barba e
ainda tem a possibilidade de cortar o
cabelo porque nós temos cabeleireiros
parceiros do projeto que corta o cabelo
dessas pessoas dignidade simplicidade
aprendemos a ser simples com essas
pessoas o gesto simples o como um café
da manhã de uma forma diferente na
calçada com dois amigos em situação de
rua se tornam prazerosa
e capazes de alegrar o nosso dia
o interessante nesse dia foi ver as
pessoas que passavam pela calçada nos
olhando assim
isso aí foi feito próximo ao semáforo e
os carros que passavam para você mafa a
maioria das pessoas abaixavam vidro e
ficava olhando aquela cena tipo que
esses malucos estão fazendo aí nada
demais apenas tomando um café na casa
dos marcos que por sinal foi o primeiro
amigo em situação de rua que o projeto
entrega para cuiabá
ajudou aprendendo que temos nós
aprendemos que temos nossos limites
temos nossas limitações
nós não conseguimos salvar o mundo a rua
nos mostra que não somos super heróis
por mais que queiramos ajudar essas
pessoas muitas vezes elas simplesmente
não querem ser ajudados por exemplo o
seu paulo nazária
teve também na região do corpo porto o
seu paulo ele teve um câncer de
intestino ele tem uma colostomia ele tem
uma abertura na região lateral do
abdômen que as fezes ae
seu paulo amarrar uma sacola de
supermercado presa no barbante e essas
fezes ficam saindo essa sacola
seu paulo uma camiseta camiseta molhada
pela água das fezes são paulo tem um
cheiro muito forte
o ideal seria ter uma bolsa de
colostomia para recepcionar sesi é seria
uma coisa mais adequada
seu paulo vi uma situação deplorável
indigno
seu paulo operou no hospital da
universidade e eu tenho cartão do sus
dele todos os meses
eu busco dez bolsas de colostomia o seu
paulo no hospital e as entregam irmãos
são paulo nunca usou uma onça
cada hora é uma desculpa mas eu continuo
fazendo minha parte levando todo mês
portanto fracassamos fracassamos
e toda vez que isso acontece levantamos
e seguimos adiante afinal temos outras
vidas pra ajudar
olha a quantidade de sentimentos e
percepções
acabei de falar pra vocês se nós
aprendemos com as pessoas em situação de
rua
isso se resume a humanidade
nós aprendemos humanidade com essas
pessoas a sermos mais humanos
mas claro como é que você aplica essa
humanidade que você aprende com a
população em situação de rua na sua vida
eu amo o que eu faço está dentro de sala
de aula é o melhor momento do meu dia
eu respiro na minha vida eu sou
professor do curso de medicina da ufmt
oito anos que convivo diariamente com
alunos em uma relação muito próxima
eu posso afirmar uma coisa aqui pra
vocês
a medicina está doente está precisando
de uma cura de uma ajuda urgente alunos
residentes professores médicos estão com
a saúde mental abalada altíssimos
índices de depressão e suicídio nos
quatro cantos do brasil
isso tá muito sério muito grave não é
divulgado
isso é velado além disso a relação
médico paciente está cada vez mais
superficial
há uma falta de contato sabe de carinho
de atenção de cuidado da maioria dos
médicos para com seus pacientes
vimos hoje aqui duas pessoas falando da
nanomedicina o papel da fa da palavra de
um médico tem na vida de que pode
destruir a vida de uma pessoa
você vai ao médico hoje em dia ele
pergunta o que você tem que examina
rapidamente uma benzida manda você
terminar determinado a retomar
determinado remédio perde os exames e
próximo paciente e próximo paciente o
próximo paciente assim vai
ele malemá perguntou sabe um homem dos
pacientes
isso é muito importante saber que o seu
joão que a dona maria que ele tem uma
história ali um ser humano
na maioria das vezes porque esses
pacientes mais precisam é de um remédio
ultramoderno de uma técnica de
diagnóstico de última geração
eles precisam de carinho e atenção um
olho no olho um bate-papo salvador
eles precisam ser escutado os e eu
perceber que tudo isso que eu aprendi
essa humanidade
eu poderia aplicar aos meus alunos saiu
do conhecimento de sala de aula e
vivenciar isso na prática na rua hoje é
uma realidade que boa parte dos
voluntários de entrega por cuiabá são
meus alunos alunos de outros cursos da
ufmt e de outras faculdades particulares
da cidade
eles estão tendo a possibilidade de
vivenciar diferentes tipos de
vulnerabilidade social
exercitando a solidariedade o amor o
respeito carinho ao próximo do ângulo
seus ouvidos e atenção aos amigos em
situação de rua para quem sabe quem sabe
no futuro serem médicos mais humanas
médicos que além de cuidarem do
biológico saibam cuidar da alma
o meu sonho é que esses meus alunos que
caminha comigo que estão ao meu lado e
dom seu coração como eu dou sejam
médicos mais humanos empáticos para com
seus pacientes
se isso acontecer eu vou estar realizada
eu seria um educador por completo tudo
terá ainda a pena
portanto quando se depararem com alguém
vivendo embaixo de pontes em praças e
calçadas
lembrem se que essas pessoas têm uma
história em sentimentos desejos
necessidades sonhos como qualquer um de
nós
elas têm muito a nos ensinar muito
elas só precisam ser ouvidas escutadas
todas essas virtudes que aprendemos com
as pessoas que vivem em situação de rua
podem ser facilmente executáveis no
nosso dia a dia em casa no trabalho nos
relacionamentos na vida em sociedade
por mais que saibamos que podemos
aprender uns com os outros
independentemente do nível social
cultural intelectual bem essa
possibilidade se permitam quebrar
paradigmas e conhecer o universo da
outra pessoa
as relações humanas são a melhor
faculdade que existe os seus
conhecimentos são profundos
indestrutíveis atemporais sejam
empáticos sejam empáticos a empatia gera
mais respeito ao outro o que gera mais
compreensão que gera mais harmonia que
gera mais amor tornando a nossa
sociedade mais humana
deixem
é importante de crer num mundo melhor
passem a criar um mundo melhor seja uma
diferença que vocês querem ver no mundo
mas comecem essa mudança por vocês como
eu conheci o pessoal daqui
daqui só se leva o amor só a mãe nada
além disso
obrigado